[Music]
[Music]
welcome my name is Stanford Anderson and
I'm the head of the department of
architecture welcome to the first of our
fall series of lectures we have an
unusually full program this fall because
we have incorporated two series inside
the full series so tonight you'll be
hearing as you know the first of three
lectures by Santiago Calatrava next week
at this same time in place we will have
the first of three lectures by young
French architects different architects
each each time in that series
that's co-sponsored with the University
of Virginia and Catholic University in
Washington and then there will be a few
other lectures as well I'm only going to
mention one of them tonight v ph
Wroblewski lecture by Renzo Piano on
October 28th and I mentioned that not
only because it's a very special event
and Eric in our fall term but also to
say that some of the books that show the
the works of Renzo Piano have been put
on reserve and Roche library under the
fall lecture series so you can find the
work to look up there and having
mentioned that we've done the same
relative to Santiago Calatrava
you'll find a group of monographs and
books on his work also on reserve we are
sponsoring the lectures of Santiago
Calatrava jointly with the Department of
Civil Engineering and in a few minutes
I'll ask Rafael broths the the head of
the department of civil engineering also
to to welcome santiago calatrava to our
series of lectures
this is a kind of double introduction
and I know that he has a lot of slides
and many things to say so I will make
the rest of my time rather brief only to
say that Santiago Calatrava
is still a very young man and with a
very large production when he visited us
about a year and a half or two ago
we enjoyed an excellent lecture on his
work and in the meantime we have pursued
to have continuing relations with him
and this is the what we think is in
hopes is the first fruit of that
discussion in connection with him and he
has prepared three special lectures for
us which in turn we hope will be another
book to put on reserve in the library
later
Satya hawa cava has as I said built
already a great deal you'll see much of
that in the lecture so I'm not going to
to be in listing the names of the works
and similarly that has resulted in any
number of prizes and any number of
exhibitions and that too is just too
numerous to mention so I think that
there's no question with the the work
that he shows we'll will speak for
himself
just one last note on my part and before
I turn to Rafael bras it is our hope
also that that's our plan and we think
it will be realized that we will have an
exhibition of models of calatrava's work
in the Compton gallery starting in the
middle of November just just after his
last lecture
Raphael hued would make a final
introduction
what about two years ago I was taking a
sleepy walk in Valencia Spain when I saw
this unusual but simple and very
beautiful bridge which really woke me up
at that point I turn around to a person
who was walking to me and asked who was
the architect and they said it was
Santiago Calatrava I frankly must admit
that at that point I didn't know who
Santiago Calatrava
was but I came quickly I'm a quick
learner and figured that I that I better
learned and immediately proceeded to try
to remedy my ignorance I asked a
colleague of mine professor Herbert
Einstein to help me on that and Herbert
took the initiative to contact dr.
Calatrava and to begin also thinking of
how we could get him evolved at MIT it
turns out that shortly after he came and
gave a lecture here they invited by the
apartment of architecture Oh the rest is
history we're here for a series by a
very distinguished architect I am very
pleased that I have learned a lot more
about him and I hope to learn a lot more
and I'm also particularly pleased to see
a joint collaboration between the
Department of Architecture and the
department of civil and environmental
engineering I think the idea of the
engineer as an architect and an
architect as an engineer is something
that we need to do better here at MIT
and I hope this is the beginning
without further ado then doctor
Calatrava thank you
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
for the possibility speaking here in
this school I think there is I would
like to make a very brief introduction
to the context and after having been a
student for a long time something like
14 years studying in Valencia and then
Zurich and I started my praxis architect
and engineer and during 16 years I have
been exactly now in November 16 years I
has been working very intensively in the
praxis the only contacts that I had to
institutions like this here was
sporadically giving a talk and for the
first time I took the commitment to give
a series of talks in the perspective to
communicate this experience as good as I
can do I think it makes sense because 16
years is a period of time who are as
important in my life as the previous
period of almost also 14 15 years and
also because 15 years defined a little
bit the generation also a net up in the
life of a person and I am combines that
things that I am saying I am saying it
to the next generation because those 15
years you find a circle around a person
of some 30 years of people who will set
the mean bind order styles and will find
his own way as much as I also interpret
the works of those who has been working
before me in all the modesty I said I
think also it makes sense also before
because the previous time that I spent
because also I got a lot from the
University or I got also a lot of my
teacher I also was quite a if not a good
a very patient student because I he
spends a long time and I think DC
an important point to underline the
second point is that I has tried to a
structure in a very simple way
you see which it is probably lactate the
wrong way to do it and also to speak and
the thoughts you see on this perience in
those here and again after having tried
in several interpreted in several ways I
thought the best it is to speak on my
own experience because in the fact this
is the only thing that I can communicate
so speak on my own experience I mean to
look back to the works that I has done
and to try to introduce you in very
essential thoughts and steps who permit
me you know to continue working during
those years and to go from one building
to another and try a little bit
implement a little bit more and a little
bit more fold and just in in a very
elemental and let's say an direct way to
communicate you this experience of the
16th years then once I decide that I had
to divide it in several in several
groups and/or and so I chose the idea of
the material as the very first one
because the material seems to me you see
as an approach to the architecture and
maybe the most substantial way I mean
from the ruins of the architecture at
the less you see you have just some
stones there something like that so I
mean the material part of the
architecture is in my opinion let's say
the physical support of the architecture
it seems to me to be very very important
I'm very fundamental and I also found a
consultation you see on this and it is
reading or trying to find an old
definition of architecture you see a
very old definition of architecture or
what what is an architect let's say I
found one who I think is has been
transmitted into our days
let's say untouched I suppose and touch
and who is very old it comes from the
time of the Egyptians from the time of
the construction of the pyramids 6,000
years ago or something more maybe 7,000
years ago and it is interesting because
it is but the definition is very much
related not only to the person but also
very much to the materials that this
person can work with so for example is
they they speak about gold bronze brass
stone wood and could imagine gold bronze
and silver you know there was all
previous material you know today - you
see gold is maybe more precious than
silver much more than bronze but at this
time you know - Koto's material was very
difficult and to work with them also
certainly means to proceed technology
and things like that and I will read you
that
and the Lord spoke in to Moses saying
see I have call-by-name Bezalel the son
of Yuri the son of hora of the tree view
of Judah and I have filled him with a
Spirit of God in wisdom and
understanding and in knowledge and all
manner of workmanship to devise skilful
works to work in gold and silver and
brass and in cutting of stones for
sitting and carving of wood to work in
all manners of workmanship well this is
from the Exodus and it is interesting
you know in the verse number three it's
a I have filled him with the Spirit of
God in wisdom understanding and
knowledge and immediately after that in
the verse number four he said to devise
a skilful works in gold silver and brass
if you make a correspondence between the
two verse you will understand also that
foreign
architect or an engineer or whatever
because at this time they was not
different you know between architects
and engineers the idea of wisdom
understanding and knowledge for this man
was like gold silver and brass precious
materials of the time and I think is
very expressive you see often and very
alive because at the same time you see
you see at the one side you have almost
like you see you have the person you see
with those quality at the other side you
have the materials so to let's say in
these terms I thought that probably you
see is a good a good understood first
step to go ahead in the understanding of
architecture is to understand what this
concrete what is still what is food you
know in our time how to use them but
this signifies you see what is what are
the form that you can achieve what are
the difference between the forms can you
go from one form to another using the
same material and this is what I want to
try showing you simply you see from the
very first steps you see into the last
works so this is a small small figure
done by using the toys pieces of toilet
and in the fact is interesting because
you see you have in the figure itself
you have yes you have healed apart then
another one then you have a whole kit
and you have two small supports like
simple support and then you have a stone
here hanging with a cord around and
hanging there and then the force of the
stone goes through all the two pieces
and it is materialized as you see in
stone food and then parts of steel and
then here are hoaxes you see also
special ones so it's a very simple way
is like an ax small toy but a lot of a
lot of context is there
you see the they also if you started you
see to look the different pieces of the
toy how the colors are put together you
see which it is simple Caswell situation
but I mean it is there is no doubt you
see that just a way to hold a stone in
the air is a matter of expression and
the complexity you see that something
can achieve and the relation you see hit
the point for example this part working
in tension they hope he also clearly
working also in tension and also this is
a spindle separating both things working
on the compression and the symmetry the
symmetry of the whole figure is also
important this is one of the very first
works that I have done it is nice
because is related to a music school in
Sangala this is a music school for
children's and they have had an auditory
ahed and then they need to extend it to
the next room and so we have just simply
to take away the wall in between who was
let's say something like 20 feet or
maybe a little bit placed by by 10 feet
high and just to support the three
floors over there it was necessary to
build a frame and so it came to this
piece here and the idea of the piece is
very simple it has two parts who are who
are done in in middle symmetric and then
they are supported here in a support who
goes along the wall so a person will be
something like that
he'd and then you see this is a simple
support and then they are five tensional
elements five then I mean it is then
let's say he up in the top I have also
two profiles who are done in double tees
they are you see the wool was coming
like that and then I has had two double
tees small to two L's and then also
small links here together and you see in
order to make it a bit more I decide to
separate the elements was working in
tension making them polish it was all in
steel only one material I have to say I
decided to do only one material like I
gave one material like with the churches
who are only done in stone or many
buildings who are simply done in then
the other was just black painted I am
doing hid with afraid but it was painted
and then the steel goes behind and with
a small element like this you see hit
the two plate
who have two symmetrical plates you see
under both sides and then I say also I
should not use any a bounding system I
mean you see the key of the evolution of
the technology and still is very
strongly related to the way not only the
quality of the steel that you produce
but also the links between the steel
when you bolt when you rip it or when
you weld you see this makes extremely
big difference in the use of steel and
in the possibilities and again the
capacity so I decided to don't use any
link so I has always for example if this
element is working in tension I have to
turn it back and Link it here where they
they let's say where the exchange of the
forces is happened in this point behind
and also even he you see the forces they
with coming here and even this small
plate you see this is just a pendula
support and it is just hold with two
pins so in a way it is like making
working working with a cart a castle you
know making with play cards see like
making a castle and then of course using
to stabilize the whole thing the frame
of the building itself involving in this
you see they part the upper part of the
building and also the side with
stabilizing this column and bringing the
force here so this is first statement
I don't know what it you see if the
details of the join here the details of
the joint and also here you see the
polish metal you see also heat the place
if we could see the other slide I don't
know if it happens we will see also day
this is of course this was also possible
because the people working also you know
they per se it also a very high level of
craftsmanship you see - - I mean to make
it in a very big very precise way
excuse me
I see yes so what also you see in this
type of approach you see there is always
a little bit a place also for the let's
say 4 y 5 C 5 elements in the fact you
see the rotation point is here and each
one of them became if not equal force of
course because those who are more
separated they have a matter of movement
when this will descend but in any case
all works under tension
I chose 5 and start to do one which it
is are redundant you understand but I do
that I could also even use to one say if
one will not work there will be another
one who will work but I decided to do 5
because as you know a music you read it
over five lines and then I found it is a
good reason isn't it to introduce a I
mean it could be also I don't know you
see the the beam could also maybe
suggest a guitar or something like that
but this is not the case in certainly
not the case but the five lines in any
case you see I think you make also
something like that here when you
started putting in the novel yeah okay
you see it here thank you
you see here the pendula element here
and then the five order then I
discovered also by the on the way I
discovered also that the width of the
tension on member of one was so big that
they was simply hanging isn't it even if
working you see I neglected the problem
of the own width of the element you see
who will for example a cable-stayed
bridge will be fundamental because you
will have you see it will even change
their model II well it is a kind of way
to understand what is the you see the
singing in very long cable and then what
we do it is we put a small support in
between and load them in the lowest one
you see it well here it was a kind of
improvisation as you see here
yes now you see another type of work
that I have done was also related to
interventions in other buildings for
example in this case disease and school
and I have had to introduce a an interns
central element a live roof of the roof
the library and also roof the ala and I
thought you see I wanted to go one step
more and introduce another element let's
say you see and the element is not only
the material quality that I will change
in several cases you see what I mean I
will work for example let's say one part
in concrete and steel another part
working purely in steel and glass
another one wood and steel or wood wood
and concrete and so having choice this
dialectic of changing material you see a
to experiment in each one of the
different solutions you see a new
solution for a roof with a particular
material I thought also it could be
interesting to work with the light you
see which it is in my opinion the life
I mean to the control of the light for
the particular space and this is the
entrance in the interims
the idea of the interns is was generated
by the fact that the plan was like that
and then I put with a diagonal element
you see I create a canopy very strongly
related to geometry you see who will
consist in recreate let's say two cones
with a diagonal position arc and with
the interns here and this will work like
that and like that and not only like
this but also to have the cross section
with a pipe who is who has a certain
resistant to the torsion and will take
also the gutter with it to have it
related to the facade so in the fact you
see even if this has a torsional
stiffness
that I have maybe used also in other
things like preaches a torsional
stiffness of the pipe or the axial pipe
but in this case I fix it into the top
of the facade with which I create a link
between facade and canopy and so the
facade and the canopy works to get that
they are solved in the same gesture and
they are also coherent as far as as far
as you see as far as the facade and
let's say the canopy has to do an
ensemble and has to became a single
thing you see here two views of the day
interns and then you see also little a
detail a detail at the end with how it
arrives you see with this kind of pink
green tie where the water at the gutter
the water is coming down also they are
some details like for example here the
glass don't touch the extremity not here
more because it's covering the whole
facade but not that they and then you
see also some data from the interior
into the exterior the wall was a small
intervention but that for me was as I
tell you as a kind of workshop of
experimental workshop was very very
important also you see it was a time in
which the relation with a craftsmen you
know we came for me also a kind of
prolongation of new school and of course
you see as it happens within the other
you see the basic idea of independent of
the fact you see of the construction it
is clear looking at the especially at
elevation that the idea you see of of
live or the idea of palm you see very
figurative idea you see I mean it's not
you see was part of the design this is
without any doubt or I mean or even it
could be maybe more beautiful like that
so there is certainly behind the very
first approach the free approach into
the architecture
that I had looking for inspiration in
natural forms and also looking to find
my my own language you see in a very
simple approach in the simple
observation of this what was running me
or thin who motivate me was a very
important as much as let's say as almost
as much as the material or you see here
also this is a second space when you
come into the interior of the school you
re you arrive into the central space
they the photograph they are not
terrible but it doesn't matter you made
maybe understand there is a kind you see
there is a cupola who is circular and
then the cupola is a use for in this
case food and as you see observe also
the fact of the light coming in and the
way how the light is here goes decrease
the see also how the border disappeared
the back border in the light you see
also heat the part in still the tension
member also the spindles here supporting
a being part of those triangles and the
lantern in the center of the Cobra and
the you see in this case the choice of
the shape was very simple you see I
going out from a circle subdividing it
in segments in radial segments cutting
them here and those radial segments you
see was done using a vu I mean the basic
shape was something like that let's say
something like that and in this whoa you
see I cut a part here you see who makes
you see in plan you see
keeps a shape like that opening the
interior and leaving the possibility of
putting heat a single element you see to
signify the compression in this party
the other side you see a in elevation
you see you will see the element working
like that and having a resultant you see
I said I separate you see sometimes just
in order to to to put in seeing all the
different type of support and recreating
him a free ring you see around who is
the ring that you are seeing in the
cross-section that we saw before you see
it here also very well you see it is
element here see also this element here
and then the support behind you see this
is the support in which the width is
coming into the wall then this is a ring
who is floating so the idea of the in
gravity you see was signified by the
fact of showing the tension ring and
hitting or not hitting but putting back
you see in the corners here the support
of the real supports of the cupola so if
you has here a band as it is the case
there you see and this is let's say is
visible but it's not significant then
you get the impression let's say that
the whole thing is floating in the in
the space in interior space and well as
you see also this East seems to me also
to be important it is you see is clear
when you see all those shapes like that
very much the whole shape can be
associated to the petals the petals you
see and
hey now you see it was a library also to
be covered and you see first of all I
thought also important as before is also
the idea of the light even more in a
library the control of light and the
relation of the light with the space is
very important so I thought it's
necessary to liberate the walls and to
have tangential light let's say a as we
can maybe we'll do you see because also
is also important to watch you see how
other people has been reacting you see
tooth material and to the use of light
and so I decided to make the roof at
interior floating and as you see you see
that main support is a column the water
is coming in you see and this is a kind
of shell who is subdivided in several
shells so it's not our Orthodox shell in
terms of deeper below it a parabola it
or segments of it but it's quite a
free-form
however you see we has in several
direction sometimes we have right lines
or almost right line and then the first
you see having as a plan you see having
as a plan such a situation
I thought you see this is the position
of the roof so the plan of the roof very
it was very rigid and then I chose a
center let's say almost the center of
gravity is not the case but and then I
decide to hold just laterally the
corners you see in order that it don't
move laterally you see that it is well
fixed but the whole support let's say
the width is going through the central :
in which also the water is coming down
and then light will be same along the
along the walls you see tangentially now
about the genesis of the idea I think
also it's important to signify that here
I started thinking you see let's say I
started thinking on the idea of a poke
see an open book
and also the idea of against like in
several other cases you see very much
idea of the elevation of the roof you
see of emphasizing very much the idea of
floating you see the roof should float
you see which it is also a tema in which
I think you see the idea of lightness is
very much given often because the contra
position of materials or of statical
systems as it was before the spindle you
see the support you see of the hoof the
support in relation to the roof you see
even if this is heavy and this is light
you see but this this contra position of
the two materials and the light coming
on the side you see will make that the
whole roof seems to fly it means you see
the book you see who was in the fact the
basis you see of the shell who was also
conceived like this so in a way you see
wanted to became also at the other side
let's say something
like a bird or something like that you
see so it is a kind of superposition of
ideas you see but coming simply from the
idea of a book because if you look also
you see if he'd also
don't have any what you see is the idea
of leave you see or something like that
hold in this support yes you see here
also the corners with the supports that
I show before you see the small links
just to stabilize the shell the shell
who turns around and also you see here
the interior of the Liberia with the
shell very close also I mean the
presence that the physical presence of
the shell at interior was also very
important now you see something who also
is very interesting it is a construction
process you see how you build things how
people you see and sometimes you see the
way how you decide you build things
decide also the shape of them the width
of them because you have to transport
them because you have to produce them
somewhere and transport it and it is
sometimes very important you see to
recognize those things and I mean they
are in my opinion until now there has
been never been decisive but they
influence very much you know the way how
things are done and you see here those
are part of the roof of the owl ah when
they was transported and he also how
they was put over the roof also making a
wooden shell you see over there you know
with arcs at the interior
you see also here how they came down and
the joint this is also very interesting
to see the fact of the : the support
and also you see something who is very
interesting it is especially when you
precast I like very much Brut concrete
you see concrete down on site but also
precasting concrete can be very nice
this is you see for example our formwork
because then the freedom in the choice
of forms and the complexity that you can
achieve is even matter and remember you
see concrete in my mother language you
see in Valencia we used to say for me go
for me go comes from forma in Spanish
you also say or McGann with H h or
McGann who is F of the forma for McGann
who means is the material that you can
give a for this mate maybe be a good
definition of concrete and so you are
very free you know choice in the shape
and also the quality and the texture and
many other things and then you see when
when we wanted to produce the pillars of
the this space you see if you have to do
a formwork who is let's say three meters
high once you fill it you get a huge
pressure in the page and then you have
to do a very complex form work and you
have to pay a lot of money for it
so how to do that you see with less
money is just cut the colon in two and
make two form works and pull it
horizontally and then glue the two parts
isn't it and this is what we have done
if you see here the two parts of the
colon you see produce horizontally it
another advantage you see you has almost
all the parts are has a formwork you see
they so even the bay the basis
everything is concluded you don't have
any place in which you has been casting
the concrete you see here this is
concluded : you he you see here also
detail of the joint that we will have
them later on
you see he also taking away putting the
two forms here you see this should be
the other way around but it doesn't
matter and then you see here also taking
out from the formwork and he also how
the columns works together then we use
epoxy poxy and also pins you see to do
in order to have also a resistance into
the shear forces a transversal resistant
and you see these are the concluded
columns and this is the side of you see
when we has been putting the columns
there then you see also always on the
side you see it's interesting also we I
decided to put a small plate here
because the link between wood and
concrete is done by this plate and
another transversal plate who is coming
in and then this is the pin who links at
the plate in today or who defined in a
way the articulation you can always read
the joint of the column you see the
vertical joint and then this is some
views of the oblah when it was concluded
so if I made maybe just give you some
references you see to this shape you see
what I wanted to achieve was quite
simple you see this is first of all you
see I propose you see to move in this at
this time not to put a roof into the
wall but to make it emerge
let's say here and then to create a
parabolic arc at the interior
and then to have hit a shell independent
and then to have here a cutter four
times and then to have a very light
window longitudinal because this will
also bring light in interior and
especially emphasize very softly the
lighting here and also bring
transparency with all those elements who
are all regularly and all equal yeah
they have all the same side let's say
they are all pieces of wood by let's say
something like three inches by three
inches very standardized this is a
laminated wooden Ark and this is another
one and then in the top I have the shell
you see or you see a control block a of
wood over there and this is the head of
the colon that you saw before and let's
say well this is a bit wider in the
proportion a person is something like
that in the in relation to the whole
thing and someone sitting something like
this but this is much wider this is so I
basically this is a parabolic arc who is
holding let's say the width of the whole
roof inside and with itself is
stabilized by Toso plickers element who
are just being in the width you see of
the of the roof into this arc may be
another point also who can be
interesting to know it is against you
know like in the interim you see the
idea of you see of let's say of a
boundary see and also what I thought it
is interesting you see this is maybe
also very figurative you see but I feel
very free I feel very free at least at
this time I continue is also feeling
like that but I mean I was thinking you
see I would like to do to express the
idea of the force coming here and many
people think this is a kind of mini
sense of a Corinthian capital which it
is not the case it's more you see it is
the head of
Hey
although it's interesting you know also
if you want you see the Corinthian
capital could be also the head of the
women I mean it is not we are not very
far away and here you see also all the
views of the space you see it's also
interesting because a space st still is
very intimated and you see the decision
of also using wood was i think there is
also picture in which we can see how the
life yes this is a good you see this is
this is with artificial light you see we
have lamps in the wall that when you
alighted the interior of the wooden
patterns you know you became very nice
you see a very nice contrast between the
light at the interior and the light at
the exterior and the shadow patterns
also of the views into the now you see
this is also interesting to see this
project close to the other I always
spoke about a kind of research research
research research passionate in terms of
other architect another of Corbusier
will say research pacient
because you need a lot of patient you
know until a building is concluded or
something like that you need really the
patient a lot and you see is interesting
also the fact once you discover a shape
and you have used a material you are
always or often tended to change
material and to use almost a similar
shape in another context because so this
happens in this particular project in
Toronto which it is a Galleria in the
center of Toronto the building here is
the toronto-dominion bank done by Mies
van der Rohe Linden Danton and this is I
think the Bank of Commerce done by IM
Pei in the center of the city and this
is a Galleria who I will show you
you see the basically the construction
principle is very much inherent or I
mean or the idea is very much inherit of
the idea of the other roof however what
there was was food is here than using
steel and also was there the control of
the life was much more laterally done
and here the light is just filtered
through the steel pattern into the
ground with the shadows in the ground
and you see let's say if you look in
elevation I don't know if I have a slide
which yes you see well also interesting
it is the fact you see of the relation
of this gallery a drop in between of the
offices and also the Clarkes and golden
building and into the Heritage Plaza you
see you have this kind of steel
construction who is just dropping you
see and you see it is like I mean it
this could be a good understanding of
the problem it is if you have on the
street and then you have let's say trees
or whatever or you have trees you see
both sides of the street you can define
an array see for me it was also easy you
see two then the trees in the case of
that they are very simple they are just
you see going like this and then the
beams just put over there then is
interesting when I have had to change
that is a certain moment in which we are
over spanning over the Clarkes and
Gordon building what I create is here
just a frame and then the tree was no
more necessary because there was a
triangle it frame going over all the way
along because this is quite an
aesthetical hi and then you see the
trees in the fact they are situated like
these situated like that then I come
back into the facade without very much
touching the facade and then I have hit
the gutter the corner here also
and this is Clark laced out of outside
and this is ten the frame who is
filtering the light into the interior
and this can be the elevation this can
be the elevation a person made can be
something like that because in this case
the high is something like 22 meters
it's a bit higher than before however
you see the whole thing stays
independent of the surrounding buildings
something who also encouraged me you see
in this way I think it was not decisive
but encouraged me very much you see to
bring this idea of the tree you see of
the tree and of the tree of the a layer
of tree because looking in perspective
you see there are many of those trees
it is the fact that as you know the you
see it was in Canada and Canada is one
of the few countries except Lebanon who
makes reference to a tree in his flag
you see he has the Mapple the mob will
leave and I think this is so beautiful
isn't it to have a tree as a sign tree
and I thought well this certainly works
with whole idea you see he also from the
plaza you see into the Galleria and you
those are two big windows who are
operable these are also you see you see
here how the windows moved down in steel
and then you see here also the
independence of the facade from the
gallery and also the lasing of the
Galleria it gives the shadow pattern you
see it here not only in the ground but
also in the facade and here some figures
on the mountain montage of the so the
construction process was also in this
case extremely well studied by the
construction manager who achieve in a
very short time you see a period of time
the montage of the whole
using very very rational systems you
know invented by itself you know for
putting a support you see mounting the
arcs at the end and moving them into the
definitive position almost sliding them
sliding them in those two tracks here
you see I'm putting them into the
definitive position because having built
the the ground of the Galleria it was
almost impossible to circulate with a
heavy crane in the interior so they use
a crane just in the interns and then
charge they pull through all those
elements one after the other and put
them there also those are photographed
in the shop if we can get this a little
bit better focus eyes you see because
they are you see also once you see those
photo for for me you see as a European
this is very much North America you see
because the pieces are so big and the
shops are ready to do those unbelievable
big pieces they dig just the half of
building and build it at once and then
bring it then you see here also during
the montage of the trees at the interior
also always you see welding on the side
a lot of welding and also a lot of bald
links and well welding links you see
also during the march of the trees
and here at the end of the hall yes and
this is during the night you see at the
end the plaza and then the Galleria yeah
now you see this is a completely
different context and who also is very
much related to the use of materials and
do you see working in a very old
building you see in which you made maybe
have a mini sense of part of the
building you know of who are let's say
700 years old something like that this
is a building in Basel in spelling HOF
so it's one of the oldest this was they
yes the city the City Council used to be
there
the very first city council and then
they move into the old city council
actual so that the building is as I tell
you one of the very very old buildings
imbecile with wooden structures and also
stone structures that we have had to
respect and to trade with a lot of K and
also to trade them accord with with
people who are specialized in the
treatment of it why the material plays
an important role it is because you see
the context by itself is so strong that
in my opinion or at least I has had in
this case you see I I thought the way to
overcome that in in modern terms or this
what I can interpret modern term it is
very much you see relating it to modern
material for example steel glass and
other things and also to introduce
single pieces you see and create a
dialectic between new and old almost
living untouched the old parts for
example living and touch the wood and
however having here a leg you see in
steel and also having heat the staircase
in steel and however having those old
walls he renovated according to the
conditions that they did well what I has
not explained it is what I had to do it
is a small theater a cabaret theater and
interior of this instructor called a
Bradley school it's just as more placing
with something something like 50 persons
can
60 persons can get together this is then
the Carter Rob is necessary a minimum
and infrastructure so a guard rope was
done then you see here the guard rope
how opens the door dedicated the table
of the guard robed in and staircase
going up into the upper level in which
it was the theater you see here the
staircase the staircase is done by using
glass you see it from the from down to
up and from up to going down and then
this big piece of metal this big piece
of metal who was also at the other side
holding a big load coming up because one
of the other things that we need to do
it is to make a create new static
condition for the new loads of the
several theaters and the new uses of the
house according to the new codes and you
see here also again the staircase as a
single piece you see in the center of
the building and then also this is
through the staircase into the cell in
which you see here this is put
horizontal now and you see hit the wall
with one of the oldest wall at the end
of the space one of the all this this is
a Gothic cell for example here you see a
gothic cell with the staircase here and
then you have hit the bridge going from
the Gothic style into the other cell so
you come in here you go up you go into
the Gothic cell and then you go into the
space and here during the construction
of the piece you see those are the steel
pieces and then here you have the people
working on the shop you see and putting
the pieces together many of the of the
details of the conclusion detail has was
necessary to do them on the side you see
or I mean not on the side but on the
shop you know discussing with the people
doing that not only calculating but also
very much you know by hand you see
saying how to conclude you see it here
also how to do the holes or how you see
very much
details of of the conclusion and the
joints and many other things so in a way
you see the work of a main structural
piece can became very much like an ax
sculptor you see here also this is the
interior space of the Sal and this is
the guard rope you see so basically we
have done two new rooms this is one and
this is another one and then you see
also here some details of the beams and
and also here the car drop the gun drop
is interesting because being in this
space you see I wanted to touch it less
as possible but however you see it has
to work as a guard rope so it hasn't
mirrors and then it could be deployed
and opened for the uppers are then this
is also the bar and interior who could
be open and closed and also the windows
you see I have to dark the space then
they can open a growth went like a
jacket when you get hot
and this is also the guard robe in which
you see you have this ambiguity you see
it was necessary to lock the guard room
because it was only one person to serve
the to card robes you know the upper and
the lower so it was decided to lock this
here and then go up so it was also
possible to introduce these activity so
personally I think if I can step back
just to give you some comments on this
work you see
materials in this case helps very much
to overcome the problem because it's
such a responsibility you know to stay
in front of a building that you are
happy when you have an especially if you
have a so-called Dagmar fleiger
who is almost taking you know is the man
who look for the monument you see who is
almost taking all the responsibilities
about the you see things how you need to
leave them the things that you can touch
those that you can not touch and then at
the other side you see also you get a
certain freedom even if very restrained
to then introduce several pieces and
create a tema in this case one Thema was
the idea of the versatility you see
things opens and close the guard robe
who can be transformed the interims the
tours and and so and another Thema was
the central staircase who even if it was
just to give you a small reference and
this piece you see even if it was a
piece you see who was basically was like
this we had to hold a very big eccentric
load coming in this place and the old
wooden roof was like that and it was not
able with regular pimps you know to hold
that so we introduced an support here
and then recreate an element at the
interior who was like that and then he
another support see between those
supports we had a balcony in between and
then here we have had a staircase that
you saw before this is the staircase
quite a steep by the way and the still
staircase was not touching here it was
almost floating so that you see this is
basically it is a three three
articulated element this was also
articulated here when the staircase is
a whole here together
and then even from this element we hold
you see the roof then in order to
achieve Junction here we have had a
piece that I was like an egg done see as
a transition between this load and the
steel structure so that people in this
case could walk here and also go up
through the staircase
there so this is the basic it was as I
do so also quite a free-form
you see with and the other part you see
they was more or less an exotic there
was a small pieces you see like the the
doors of the guard robe or the central
guard robe yes this is also one of the
let's say also an early work in which
let's say if in the previous one you
know the relation between modern and old
and the choice of the material plays an
important role here was almost an
exercise how you see how to claude
claude claude an existing an existing
shop where were house you see and give
him a new signification and then the
resources was - first of all we was you
see the choice of the material the
choice of the material first and so it
needs to be a very economic or a very
cheap material or a very economic
material so we so we decide to use
aluminum crude and concrete good because
it is the almost you see the regular
aluminum that you can get very easy and
then you can get it also corrugated you
can get it flat you can get it in many
ways and is easy to work with and then
another resource was you see how to
transform this building not only with
the cladding but also finding a tama and
the Tama was even if they you through
the limitation of the material you see
we create a big restriction see but it
was a kind of pinned Pinto risk
I mean Pinto risk in the meaning of
painting pinterest in the meaning of
painting or I mean each facade should
appear like a different painting or like
a different facade even using the two
material so the material will create the
unity will create the unity and the
treatment of the material in each one of
the facade will create an the Tama that
it makes
a facade of the other for example in
this case you see here the South facade
is done by using corrugated aluminum
aluminum but the corrugated aluminum you
see is put you see the elements of the
corrugated aluminum as you know you see
the corrugated aluminum is something
like that then we took those elements
and then we make a sinews and then we
put a corrugated metal like that so we
became a double rigidity because let's
say two pieces with a transversal links
you see it became then not only let's
say
modulated but also very rigid in this
way so it permits to make quite high
element you see in the facade then in
order to emphasize this this movement
here in cross section we cut them like
this and cut them like that so that even
you see looking from the front you see
the view of the scene so it will be even
more accentuated even looking into the
top of the building you see the view of
the scene so it will be clear readable
and also because the this even if it is
also aluminum it is put in client these
will stay appeal black because it is
under the shadow or it became the light
in another way then even in order to
make more plastic unreadable you know
the client came and say 4/6 safety
reason I need a lot of light in this
area here and so we put lamps you see
the exterior of the facade like that
small lamps but we took them far away of
the facade so that you will see also the
shadow of the lambs you see follows also
from time to time the curves and then
makes also drawings in the facade not
only the vertical component and then
this is quite let's say a plastic
relation interesting is also that this
is the South facade
it means the movement of the day and the
hours of the day will also make very
significant if accan change in the
facade itself
you see here you can also see well the
shadows of the light and also the
reflection of the Sun and also this you
see here also and also the vibration the
vertical vibration produced by the
reflection of the Sun in the facade
let's say this is a work who has been
done something like 12 years ago this is
also you see depending in the hours of
the day also the facilities is simply
sensible you know when you get a very
rezoned light you see or vertical one
and then what it is also interesting it
is this shadow here is this is also pure
aluminum and here also you see the cut
from which I spoke before you see with
the way how it floats and moves over the
concrete structure then this was the
other Thema this was the North facade
see I spoke about the problem of you see
the verticality also is very generous in
the South facade isn't it
now in the North facade the problem was
different because you see the North
facade has just seen it light you see
San it light means a very diffuse line
now how to emphasize the plasticity of
whatever the thing insane it light so so
I propose to use an S profile just cut
out you see this is one piece in metal
and the other one you see we have here a
piece to fix it you see and then again
another one and those are pieces very
very long with a joint you see may be
they are let's say 10 meters with 30
feet long and then they have a joint and
another joint so as long as possible the
Internet of this into a unit is that you
will get here you see quite a reflection
here you will get shadow
this will be almost black then you will
you will get a bit less
reflection going into this very high
reflection and then again less and then
it will break in a in shadow so you will
get not only a linear structure but also
in the linear structure you will sin
civilize the structure also to this and
it light and this here again in frame in
a frame with the basement and because we
have had windows here who pre-exists we
also incorporate them in the whole
modulation in the whole longitudinal
modulation even an in turns into into
the back side and even incorporating
that into the building you see it here
well you see the the linear effect you
see these parts who are more plastic
those who are also too interesting
element you see this is the use of those
plates you see just trying to find all
type of use of this element you see we
recreate here you see those are
corrugated plates who are 17 meters long
in one piece it was just you see the
problem was not to you see it was just
to put them on the side you see in one
beam 70 meter from the top into the
button and I'm holding them here with a
small element in the top and also with a
small element so that a very flat
backside of East Side you know
confronted to the sunlight you know very
horizontal and the Morning Sun and then
there was an elevator body here that it
needs to be clouded and in order to
distinguish it so was the proposition of
using I think you say scales scales like
a fish scale of in German I will say
Shindell of but very big ones with a
very big of aluminum
you know cladding it turning around the
corners you see turning around the
columns are also turning into the top
even if the race was angular it it was
also a beautiful way you see too in this
order facade you see to get in this flat
east side of
the building you see to get the two
towers it was too you see to get them a
bit as let's say with the scales going
down like that you see and then in
framing the whole thing you see in you
see and using those seventeen meters
high vertical lines you see I'm
presenting a very flat facade that
during the day when the Sun turns you
see those element has the tendons also
to give a shadow against that and then
became much more plastic with also an a
small service door you see four in the
corner this is another so any each one
of those facades could be conceived you
see like a separate a separate picture
also the corner here the corner was very
important you see the corner expecting
to you see to put here and sculptor
which until today has not happened just
at the time was for economical reason it
makes maybe be one of those days there
you see now you see how to give a global
idea you see well before that I have to
explain you also you see the doors you
see the West facade in opposition to the
East facade and having almost the same
light condition you know Sun rising and
Sun setting you see was also done using
those very big panels you see those very
big panels and then you see the lamps
you see the lamps and the doors when
they are closed for example a possible
lecture of the lamps and there are many
lectures of those things you see they
are like shields you see putting the
table you see they have a lamp behind
and they give a transversal lighting but
if you look for example the slide that
you have there you see you can imagine
one lamp another lamp
and at all and it is and you see this is
the other point it is the eye you see
now you see I spoke about the Pinterest
case may you see it means you know
different paintings like you see
different sculptor something about how
to link them you know how you see the
problem was from the very beginning it
was a foreign body yes a strange body
you see it was not something that we
have done we have to give a life to this
body isn't it
we have to give a life you saw the doors
before and this is you saw also if I can
step just a moment back also you see
this place for the sculptor you see this
is the place for the sculptor and then
if you bottom you see it here again
and then here you see you saw the doors
and the facade now the scales and many
other things so if I do an axonometric
of the building you see we could say
this is one side then I have here the
gate
and then this is the building so you see
lorries come in and out every day a lot
of them see mainly Rory's waiting the
door check the gate open the big gates
open and the lorries come in and then
goes out if I put the skull of the eye
with those here you see the whole
building games little bit like it so the
whole building we can is a kind of under
the lorries you see coming out and in
you see is like a history of Jonas so
yeah I want also to do another small
drawing very this is very famous you
know that and then
is the elephant and the snake isn't it
of santak super II you see I mean it is
also it's very important this kind of
game in which you see the idea of you
see in the beginning the toy of the
children's your it's the toy of my
children I mean it's not you see I make
that with a choice of my children's so
it was an exercise for me to take the
toys of my children and things of my
house you see to hint the curtains you
see whatever you see pencils and
whatever I found you see to do that and
in a way you see is also a matter of I
mean the lemon Terra T of the thought
takes absolutely no force to the
complexity of the solution you see what
I mean in the beginning something can be
extremely spontaneous and simple see
what I mean you I want to walk you know
where I am going on an assignment that's
a question but you know to work is just
a very natural thing I mean the thing is
where my steps are bringing me but I am
also arriving there step by step isn't
it and a step is a very simple thing and
a very long trip you know need to be
started in a small step and so sometimes
you see those thoughts you see are you
see is in my opinion an effort you see
to from the petrous to pass to the
literary you understand and to give to
the whole thing a force at least in my
mind if the people don't read it like
that let let me tell you is not
important and I think here you see I
feel as I tell you he surrounded of
people and I want to communicate a very
intimate perience and so I don't worry
if it's sometimes it looks a little bit
like a talk isn't it then you see hit
the door you see also you see also for
example the linearity of the this is
modular and this is the almost the same
module but it is a continuity in that
also there is also behind that a very
beautiful idea it is the idea of a
facade who can be transformed I think in
my opinion in
transformation I will come in in my last
talk to that you see about metamorphosis
and the idea of the metamorphosis this
is a mother of evolution in the
architecture and unbelievable mother we
dispose you see of of let's say not only
of mechanical and physical element you
know to create and recreate new
architectures based in the idea of the
of the metamorphosis but also I think we
are Matthew also in order meet and in
our understanding of culture you see to
introduce those components in a major
scale in the in in the architecture
could you imagine for example a whole
facade who get transformed you and I'm
not only that he who is charged the half
of the facade who get transformed but
the whole facade who get transformed and
can be like a curtain you know open from
one side to the other or things like
that this is in my opinion feasible
today and certainly a challenge for the
new generation for the evolution of the
architecture you see all the pieces are
a very repetitive they are all the same
johnston miss you it has been changed it
is like you see you see the measure and
the the inch is also the same
and now I would like to jump to another
subject also important because it will
show you at once you see that this what
I say before you see that in many
buildings you see the construction
process you see can be more or less
relevant when you are working as an
engineer the construction process is
fundamental for example a cantilever
ring you know bridges built in a process
of cantilevering you see the
construction process is fundamental to
understand the shape of the bridge or a
many old model type of buildings in this
case you see it was not as much a
construction process of the bridge
itself but the construction process of
all the side this is a bridging
volunteer and I would like to focus your
attention not in the bridge itself but
in the way how it was built the bridge
is over an underground station you will
see it there is a plaza down the bridge
you see there is a plaza down the bridge
there is a this is the arc the arc is
inclined as I wanted to do an arc you
know who incorporates in the city you
see as a kind of biggest culture and
then you have here you see this light
coming out from the ground you see here
also the bridge over the plaza you see
and there is as I tell you this is an
illustration heat down for underground
so people comes down and goes into the
station you see here the entrance into
the station you see here also some
details of the plus side self covered by
the bridge and he also the plaza from
the front with the light cannons
bringing light into the station itself
and here also you see an interesting
thing it is the underground of course
Don works the whole day it works only
let's say until one o'clock and then
until feed o clock a four o clock or
five o clock it's closed so I have done
the entrances into the underground that
they can be locked also so in the night
the interns disappear or let's say is
almost part of a ground floor you see it
here you see when it is closed how it
looks and there behind this open you see
here it is
you see this is the process of opening
the interior this is also a very
interesting material
you know you is very very traditional
especially from our area from Valencia
even if you have the most brilliant
exponents are in Barcelona in the works
of cavity but in all region you see
there is a lot of small broken pieces of
ceramic used for planning and see so we
use these broken pieces of ceramic
cladding the whole interior of the
station and also white concrete see this
is the station but the interior and this
is daily light then this is the side you
see sometimes I think the photograph
upside even more interesting or also the
side is as an event is also extremely
interesting you see here you see the
poles almost hull finish or finish and
also very interesting to see the light
cannons how they work because no
artificial light is there it main place
also here you see the light coming in
also here you see the part the upper
part of the of the staircases in lighted
holes here the lamps you see done in
Turin Cadiz
it is a broken ceramic lamps
incorporated to the walls and this is
the prefabricate roof of the station so
the station down the bridge was built
simultaneously and we had only 14 month
to to both things together so it was
impossible to conclude the station and
then build over the bridge nevertheless
because also the this valve is only the
dimension for a certain type of float
and not hold the whole width of the
bridge during construction so this was
you see disease after construction you
see also the skylight you know how the
skylight has been built in the plaza and
we have now to change the curve self so
the problem was how to build a bridge to
see when the station was under
construction or how to build bridge and
stage
at the same time and I mean maybe well
the solution is very reasonable you
build the bridge
apart and then you build a station once
the station is finished you move and put
a bridge on this place these are also
details of the windows order of the
interim says and then this is the side
during construction you see here is the
bridge and here is the whole of the
station this is the bridge during
construction and he was the side in
which the station was being built up
here also several views of the deck of
the bridge in steel you know and welding
you see that massive pipe of the not
pipe it is a massive steel piece you see
who became stick record of the arc you
see who spans over 170 meters who makes
around 3500 feet then you see the bridge
here before it was transported and he'd
in this case over the station you see
and to transport it we just pull it
see you see he is the people watching
this is it took several hours
see so the bridge started here and then
moves as the people watches he moves
like interesting is also to see the
cross-section of the bridge you see the
boxcar girl who is holding the torsion
of the eccentricity and inclined arc and
then also in several of our looking from
the other side you see the bridge in one
it up in another it up and in the TV
almost in the definitive position and
then hit the bridge just after arriving
into a definitive position you see also
some views also of the bridge concluded
with the open gate and a closed gate of
the station just to signify that the
station is still there now another
project you see in which and in which
what I would like just to signify is you
see I could also speak in this project
about the relation between city and
project and architecture you see but I
would like very much to resume my
intervention you know to the material
and to the construction difficulties
that we have had and about the basic
idea of each one of those projects in
this case I will just I would like to
explain you that you see the station is
situated in a hill and in a small scale
you will have let's say this is the lake
of Surak lake of zurich the lake used to
arrive here and then this is a moraine
hill moraine hill from the glade a
glacier pleasure then this you see it
was a lot of trees here and then people
arrive and make the walls of the sea
here and then this became a flat area
area and then they started building here
form that the Berkeley plan then well I
think it is that it becames the area
Bellevue in suruc flat beautiful area
with the heel of the Aubrey promenade a
SoCo later on the Rhine Road came and
make a cut make a cut here and leave two
lines and then our exercise was in this
situation you see in the situation of
the moraine to enlarge the station and
make it to a major station with a lot of
traffic you see sometimes we have each
two minutes one train it's a very very
heavy traffic station and important also
for the whole regional scheme and so now
looking to this particular element a
part I would like to emphasize you see
the different character of the two parts
who still today is concerned these very
urban and these very green you know with
the very first houses built outside of
the city see schools and so the whole
hill has a different character of that
here and now you see the new
intervention music has considered you
see the fact that there was a cut here
and this was and that we has had to step
back and cut more on the hill and in
this situation you see the decision well
the basic idea was that I would like
very much to conserve this Porter here
and also this situation there and for
that you see we I propose or we propose
see structure will permit
with
with permanent Anchorage I will explain
also the why permanent a garage will
hold the houses sometimes are here and
even also sometimes you see in a
particular case we even hold a tree a
big tree and then we recreate Gardens
here and a pergola you see in you see in
addition to the I mean not in addition
but a little bit conserving very much
the character of the outer part and
living here you see the possibility of
people dominating over there also people
waiting here to the trains then having
here an element you know to hate this
part
leaving all the anchorage accessible or
part of the anchorage in any case
accessible for supervision reasons and
then having here the other two lines and
recreating in the underground
even a shop mall who permit also to make
more save and also more interesting the
link and also to have a city of shops in
the underground who works and then you
see in contrast to that putting here a
light canopy and then having the
suspension of the cutting areas and then
the Train so this is a little bit the
scheme of the station you see just that
you pick on off the scale you see you
will find something like that now you
see as much as many other projects you
see there is always in my opinion or has
been until now for me necessary also you
see to take a little bit and approach
you see to the problem you see first of
all relating it to the city second
relating it to the construction for
example all this idea here became very
happy we have the gardens here so I tell
you the houses are here it was necessary
for safety reason to make an
independence between the wall and this
part as much as this part can maybe fall
but the wall will still stay there and
the houses will be safe for example in
case of incident the interior of the of
the station and many of the thoughts
like that you know technical natural you
know who was conditioning not only the
process of construction because
sometimes we have had from here to there
something only like 90 feet something
like that so houses was here so it was
in a very narrow and and sometimes we
are getting here into the ground you see
also for technical needs and we are
getting here until 45 feet on the ground
which it is quite much and so it was a
decide by itself also the fact that we
have had to build that you see as
leaving the train circulate the whole
time so the traffic in the station was
never interrupt so it was quite a
challenge in such a high side you see to
add up and to remove you see to try to
combine the day all the safety of the
you
of the station during the site and at
the same time thinking that from here to
there sometimes we had I think at least
27 meters you see between the space in
which we could work this was quite an
interesting thing but however I think
the lecture of the station also needs to
be another one that the pure technical
one and even if the technical problems
was as was quite a challenge and also I
was let's say quite networks because was
one of the first jobs and being
responsible at the one side of the
architecture but also of the engineering
was quite a big thing I thought well we
should also have little bit fun with the
station and you see the basic idea of
the station is not only the whole
functional complex and also the human
context and so there is another one you
see I wanted for the first time
experiment with the body you see and
with an atomic thought and I thought
under gesture and I started with my hand
you see and the the first thing was the
idea you see let's say you see of the
hand an open hand which it is a matter
of sincerity and openness and everything
you see and from the open hand you see I
chose this part and this part becames
the column
also here also here in the corners also
there here you see the vault turning
around with different pillars in still
see here also a detail of the pipe in
steel and the support and the pendular
pillar here in the in the front this is
the place where we used to fix the the a
clock then you see here during the side
you see the shapes of the form works
coming from one scientists atop was
finished then we started from the other
side coming in also a lot of provisional
small bridge was decided to be built and
then the train circulating during the
site you see here is a regular train in
the station you see it also here from
the top you know we was very close to
the houses around then this is the this
became Center promenade you see hit a
bridge in steel prefabricated also to be
mounted in the most easiest way you see
also hit the same bridge with the
connectors you see it for the concrete
it was a mixer structure with a concrete
plate also other provisional structures
and here building de canopy you see here
very well a cut on the shape then you
see the montage of one column with is
also interesting you see this is also a
point that I should explain you is well
just very fast is the fact you see the
station is not is geodetic the station
is not flat you see the train is coming
from a tunnel and going into a tunnel
and just more or less the centre is
horizontal so we has built all the
station like that and even the columns
are like that but you don't see it
because they are also inclined if they
was vertical you will immediately see it
I understand but in all the directions
they are inclined even the Galleria is
like that so the whole station I mean it
is like a sausage
yes you see he also some details of the
you see here the the foam works you know
sometimes quite complex with very very
good very good people you know making
the concrete and side very good it was
two groups of people unbelievable and
this is the Galleria just after the
finish you see this was the original
project today they had many things as it
happens today everybody want to put his
name he'd and you see and so and then
has put plastic banks here interior but
his life
then you see here also again during the
site always you know observe the side
the side can be assumed lee beautiful so
by itself even in a certain disorder you
see the sometimes you have real openings
and then the Sun comes in into the
interior you see in a way that you will
not see it
then later when it is concluded isn't it
also in my opinion aside if you like the
construction so it's a very inspiring
and beautiful place but also this mill
and I don't know that it all kind of
smells of course and you see here the
formwork you see when you work by this
post concrete you have to take a lot of
care with all the things you have to
coordinate very well the installation
for example not suspended ceilings
everything you know they they if just a
moment looking back you see those are
the hole for the lamps they then other
lamps are heat and the loudspeakers are
here everything has to be incorporated
and the coordination between project and
the different types of installations
undisciplined who comes is there has to
be very well coordinated you need a very
big fo you see to achieve that
effectively the emergency lighting and
the other light they are all
incorporated into the concrete also tell
the lamps are also part of the concrete
and loudspeakers are here and everything
so that the pure shape of the concrete
comes out you see here
and this is also when you arrive so also
another idea that what I wanted to
create a very strong structure you know
who dominate on the shop but you see
with the time you see the shops are
dominating the situation which it is
also also the senior genial ethic was
very austere you see very little very
little element you know to mark because
away is so clear and so easy to find see
here this is a shop as it was in the
beginning and then the light you see
this is the concrete you see this is
this and then the concrete over there
this is one column that we couldn't
build and then we had to suspend a hole
with those two members then you see here
the curve of the station also you see
this is another event you see the a pure
engineering event I mean you see in plan
and in elevation you know that the
trucks was given by engineers but you
see the fact of the to have a curve you
know and then to have the possibility to
look the station with 280 meters length
which it is that a 880 or 900 feet
length you see you see but it seems to
be much longer because you don't see the
end so the curve helps a lot and the
fact of you see the shape you're not
turning around like a totally you see
having this kind of of this kind of
rotational rotational geometry you see
rotational geometry in which things are
turning you see so the the idea of the
rotational geometry you see is also very
much emphasizing the idea of the dynamic
of the trains turning around so in a way
also following very softly you see
softly the Givens of the engineers you
know it was also possible to achieve
kind of dynamic also the repetition was
also a good thing for the modularity you
know all the pieces you see all the
columns were equal all the all the
segments of the of the roof was just
sometimes we had to do some concessions
in the longitudinal modulation but we
could clarify that because we make the
joints between the
works quite wide and then sometimes we
make them shorter shun sometimes a
little bit wider and you think that we
could achieve you see it is also
interesting it is to see that in the
fact that station is almost unknown
station because it disappears hidden
behind the roofs and so in the middle of
the city then three cities are trains
passing by or effects of the lighting in
the night shadows also in the concrete
and then you see as I tell you they see
today the proximity of the center of the
city into the station and also the
relation between City and station in my
opinion is very important to understand
the whole project it was not a place to
adjust you with the station it was a
place to incorporate you see the heavy
traffic of trains and to hit it and to
incorporate it but without covering it
it could be also possible to cover the
whole things and make new apartment but
in my opinion I started explaining you
the topographical situation and is a
very very particular situation in this
place with a beautiful housing up in the
top of the hill and they and the city in
the so I think it was also correct
was it like that now you see it's just a
small parenthesis to explain you an
experience with concrete which is you
see I was in charge from the Swiss
Association of concrete makers to do
them pavilion for an exhibit like cb2 a
for an interior room and who could be
used and later on for somewhere else and
then I produced this machine as a very
early try doing a machine in which I
wanted to try to put the concrete in
movement we knows concrete light windows
heavy concrete with all type of concrete
but concrete in movement is a great
thing you see and so I little bit is
rate but I don't know if you know that
agent Racine a who was the founder of
the I think the founder of the
prestressing very first pattern in
prestressing was number is Jennifer
Sinan he studied prestressing microbe
concrete and making a
for planes this Prairie was never
achieved but he do all kind he has done
all kind of so it's also extremely you
know in the 30s and in the forties
people was well in the 30s especially
the forties was a difficult year he was
let's say twenties and in the early
centuries people was extremely daring
his ideas of and the hope of the use of
the materials and I would like just to
show you that here you see and look very
much the fact that I wanted to achieve
forms who could be extremely related to
the body let's say to the body when I
say to the body I mean you see a two
in which let's say formerly you see the
inspiration was extremely or strongly
should strongly be related to the idea
of a certain sense quality of the use of
forms and just if you hold that in your
mind and we can go forward it is light
see you will maybe see shapes you see
and you will also see circular elements
and also you will see very tactile and
soft way to use concrete in a way in
which you never more think you see I
think I hope you see that you see the so
it's a kind of not only moving the
concrete but also giving it almost a
very sensual like the idea of the flash
scheme which it is possible to achieve
not using extremely sophisticated
element and so the idea of the organ is
to the idea of the detail you see I mean
the idea of you see how a piece you see
will link to the other
you see display
so in which you see the detail by itself
you see on the shape of the detail
became by itself not only I mean more
than the result of a very elaborate
geometry the result of and this will be
a section for example through here and
also who permit us you see
recreate let's say as a dream the idea
of the lost
and you see now I will show you this
project but I will not do any comment on
the construction you have I will just
show you the project which it is also
another station who follows the station
of tunnel - and I think also you have
very much to think that you see this
object was built by extremely careful
and well let's say a peg if that people
has been working there putting their
hand to put this concrete to put this
metal and everything and I think is also
very important to started watching the
buildings also from the inside into the
origin not only from the origin into the
end you see what I mean
it's very beautiful also to understand
the side of a process you know the way
how things are put and also to get close
the people who are on the side and also
because they are fundamental in the fact
they are those who put their hand and if
someone you see risk the life is
certainly not the architect there are
the people who are on the side who who
do that who goes up and so this is the
station in Lyon the station illion I
will not give very much explanation I
want just to basically is built in
concrete aluminium steel and glass it
has also granite in the pavings the
concrete is white concrete is clear
concrete is using only white cement and
natural aggregates natural gravels from
the area and sand also a little bit grey
light Sun and it's interesting when you
use this type you get a very light
concrete but also it is something in the
color of the concrete who remembers the
side because the gravels and everything
is from the area so it's not pure white
is sometimes a little beige or a little
bit grey and is yes you see here some
views of the roof you see the steel
structure and the reflects of the
sunlight here also here you see in the
aluminum as
you see the facade behind is done use
just using pure concrete and then a
glass in between you see it also here
the esplanade those are couple of stone
in granite and the handrails are all
done in concrete and also that steel and
steel and glass and then also you see
their homes of the use of the material
for example the steel never touch the
ground the steel is always ported by the
concrete like in the library for example
you see we had this spindle
I mean steel who is so you see they
still arrives here and then there is a
beam of concrete here so never you see
there is not a direct relation between
the supporting element and the ground
you see here is in the Galleria who
brings from the airport into the station
and then the back of the station he take
an area from the other side with the
roofing aluminum you see here also
another view from the front and also
here the wing
you see here also some details of the
wing you see this wing is all south
oriented and we chose the inclination in
the angle of the solstice so after the
let's say middle June the Sun is out of
the interior of the space and until
November it stays out of exactly and
then comes again seen and this facade
during the day gets analyzed in the
interior of the hall who permit to have
almost a very low climatization and the
roof works even if it is open works with
you see this is the frontal support here
also some details of the steel and the
concrete also hid away how this come
concrete also it might have been on
quite almost elephant touching the
ground then here from the front you see
all the water pipes and and support of
the roof you see this the roof is
basically an arc of two hundred and 140
meter span you see in and then all the
forces comes into this point comes into
this area here you see also here is in
my opinion quite a nice detail how they
did concrete Bend and also the border
sometimes sharp sharp borders some time
flat sometimes curved you see here also
at the interior of the building once you
are in the building you see through the
transparency into the concrete galleria
this is the concrete galleria bringing
into the trend you see here this is a
concrete galleria with the staircases
going down into the into the platforms
also the modulation use it it has been
not prefabricated only partially
prefabricated and then also big pieces
was cast on side of white concrete
concrete and steel and the ground is a
granite and here we have concrete all
over this is concrete this is also
polished concrete this is concrete and
this is complete everything that you see
here except the armatures of the windows
who are
sometimes open you see this is also
interesting when we don't have to cover
anything so we have livery leave it
except the Train we leave it open so for
example at the end of the station the
whole structure stays open and only
partially covered because we are
covering the lateral platform also you
see here the complexity of the
triangular structure we see modulated
going up with this cut here very thin
and tiny cut in the concrete
yes also this element you know there is
a tunnel because the train can pass
through the station it's a big in a big
speed so what we have done is just close
the triangles you see those triangles he
are closed with another triangle
so he's a kind of repetitive repetitive
but however who get more and more closer
into the center and more and more open
into the end yes you see also from
outside how the Sun penetrate you see
from the west side penetrate into the
interior of the structure and here also
this is also a point that I would like
just one scale I will do two sketches to
this project I think it is interesting
the first sketch are related to those
elements you see the you see I was
interested
in the idea
of recreating an instructor who is based
in a way in certain proportions strongly
related to the human body this is one
idea so many of them you see hold the
stage many of them and the whole thing
became the kind of modular basis this is
so this is one point and the second
point who I think is also very important
to understand the roof as you have seen
the shape of the station is that here
let's say this shape of the station is
this
this is the shape of the stage in the
fact you see the idea of the shape
by the idea of the eye and this is as
far important because someone say that
the painter the painter Raphael will not
have arms you know he will be such a
good architect I mean he could suddenly
not be a painter but a good architect
because a working instrument of an
architect is very much related to the
eye is division is the Faculty of seeing
and judging and inventing things to eyes
and the eyes of the mind you see to
invent it and to combine things so in
this way I want also to underline
something that all those projects in
which I has been working you know has
been also possible not only because
these people who execute them and who I
appreciate so much but also because many
people has been helping me with their
hand to see making models you know
making drawings in my office and so they
are all participial offer of this before
and of the and certainly they contribute
a lot to the project and you see here
for example this is the central gallery
going from one side to another this is
also the end you see with the bunt with
a buttress er you see done in concrete
who makes a change into the arc
in still it is the beginning of the arc
you see also the interior you see with
the concrete with a glazing and then the
interior space with the terraces you see
also two views of the interior space
then also here the glazing passant you
see in shadow because the roof is
preceded by producing a shadow at the
interior and then he - views of the
station in lighted those two slides
define the end of my talk I would like
very much to thank you for your
attention and thank to the school for
giving me the opportunity to speak to
you thank you